[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic hello
everybody out there interested in the
academic media hype complex kind of a
play on Eisenhower's military industrial
complex except apply to Academia and
little known in that speech by
Eisenhower was the following quote
this is actually his farewell speech but
in the military-industrial complex
portion of the farewell speech of course
he warned of the the unified entity a
whole where military and Industry would
come together and some say that his
warning was not heeded but little known
or lesser known as his warning about a
scientific technological Elite which he
also worried about and warned about he
said akin to and largely responsible for
the sweeping changes in our industrial
military posture has been the
technological Revolution during recent
decades
the prospect of domination of the
nation's Scholars by federal employment
project allocation and the power of
money as ever present and is Gravely to
be regarded yet in holding scientific
discovery in respect as we should we
must also be alert to the equal and
opposite danger that public policy could
itself become the captive of a
scientific technological Elite
and of course as Carl Sagan said never
has the power of science been uh so
strong and yet the Public's
understanding of science been so weak as
it is in his day which is in the late
1990s or
so part of the complex I believe uh the
academic hype cycle involves not only
money as I Eisenhower was warning about
but also the prospect of Fame attention
and even the Nobel Prize like my first
book losing the Nobel Prize warns about
uh but today we're going to talk about
something that actually has a connection
to UC San Diego and I'd hope that we
would have my colleague Jorge Hirsch on
this podcast to
uh who has been a very very vocal critic
of the claims of the discovery of a
truly room temperature
ambient superconductor using lutein
hydride which has made the rounds for
the last few weeks as it is March and
physicists gather together in a event
called the uh March Madness for
physicist it's called the the uh March
meeting or sometimes it's held in April
the American physical Society
and um and it all centers around this
article which I will show in just a
minute about superconductivity and the
claim of the absence of electrical
resistance exhibited by superconducting
materials would have enormous potential
for applications if it exists at ambient
temperature and pressure conditions
the abstract says despite Decades of
intense research efforts such a state
has yet to be realized
ambient pressures cup rates which is the
previous class of high temperature
superconducting record holders now these
cooperates are material class exhibiting
superconductivity up to temperatures up
to 133 Kelvin and so the pre-composition
they claim over the past decade has led
to new materials which can have
interesting behaviors including one that
they're reporting here in this nature
paper luteum
hydride with a maximum critical
temperature where it starts to become a
superconductor or stops as you're
cooling it down of 294 Kelvin which is
uh below which is which is effectively
room temperature at 10 kilobars which is
the amount of pressure that is
superconductivity at room temperature
and near ambient pressure and that's
important because previously the same
group more or less reported a discovery
that required tremendous pressure much
higher pressure and so they go through
the evidence that they've obtained this
behavior and I'm going to go through
their paper
um and uh with help from one of our
graduate students here Bryce Bixler has
put together this presentation and Lucas
shinebach who's also assisted me putting
together some slides for your reference
so let me just tell you though cut to
the chase in some to some extent which
is that these results are highly
controversial and it's not the first
time that this group has come up with
highly controversial concerns about over
their research
and in fact as I said there was a
retraction of a previous
um result so retraction note this is
published in September 2022 so this is
just a few months ago about six months
ago they retracted the room temperature
superconductivity in a carbonaceous
sulfur hydride the editors of nature was
to retract this paper following
Publications questions and arrays
regarding the manner in which the data
in this paper have been processed and
analyzed with the authors and nature
have been working to resolve we have now
established that some key data
processing steps namely the background
subtractions applied to the raw data
used to generate the plots into your 2A
use a non-standard user-defined
procedure I don't know exactly what that
means but all authors disagree with this
decision an earlier version of this note
stated that not all authors expressed
their opinions but the editors have
since been contacted by the missing
authors so they went to the authors they
made sure as you do when you publish the
paper that the they all agree with the
findings of the paper so what's going on
here well the discovery was basically
claimed to be uh really junk conclusions
in some sense by my colleague Professor
Jorge Hirsch here at UC San Diego now
Jorge Hirsch himself is also a
controversial character and I hope to
have him on to discuss this uh today but
it was not to be
and then the complaints about Diaz by
Jorge Hirsch here at UCSD became so
persistent and strident that other
people in the field circulated a letter
complaining about the Decades of
disruptive behavior by Dr Hirsch he
didn't really back down
um
there are other things that are kind of
interesting peculiar that we'll get into
including intellectual property and
patents and financial backing or perhaps
still lack thereof so I'm going to go
through some slides that my students
have prepared and I think it'll kind of
set the stage for why this is so
important well first of all what is a
superconductor
superconductor is a
material that conducts electrical
current with virtually no resistance
and certain things occur when those uh
when this behavior is Manifest including
things that can be tested experimentally
in the laboratory and used to verify
whether or not true superconductivity is
actually taken place
so we're conducting
materials are inherently Quantum systems
so typically Quantum systems are
destroyed by they're very delicate and
destroyed by decoherence and effects
that are occur when there's an
interaction between ambient conditions
say the Laboratories temperature other
effects like pressure magnetic fields
and otherwise so it's very difficult to
get a room temperature superconductor as
it is to get a purely Quantum state of
something otherwise
non-classical in its behavior and
actually curiously it's
discovery of the theory behind it
so-called BCS theory was the C in BCS
Theory bardeen Cooper and schreefer the
C was my Advanced quantum mechanics
professor at Brown University Leon
Cooper
put a picture of him here
and Leon came up with this apparently
according to my friend Stefan Alexander
past guest many time pass guest on the
podcast
he came up with it while riding like the
A train you know New York City in 1957
or so and they won the Nobel Prize a
year or two after I was born uh for this
and the so-called key phenomena
so-called Cooper pairs which are pairs
of electrons which you'd normally think
would be repelling each other but
they're bound together because of
interaction with the lattice us uh
quasi-particles called phonons and we'll
have some more to say about that later
on and also in our interview with Felix
flicker which will also cover the
announcement of this room temperature
superconductivity phenomena because he
was actually there at this press
conference
another thing that happens uh is the
so-called meissner effect which is that
the magnetic fields become zero within
the material they're restricted to tiny
little vortices called fluxons and these
can be obtained at uh temperatures
considered to be you know by by most
people high temperature
superconductivity is above 77 Kelvin and
that's the temperature which nitrogen
boils and it's a common cheap relatively
cheap material that's easily available
and is fact used to cool down many
superconducting materials and even
trains and other technology and the
coils at the Large Hadron Collider and
CERN and in Europe but these uh these
phenomena are not manifest
unless there is a very low temperature
it's 321 degrees below zero fahrenheit
which means 400 degrees Fahrenheit below
room temperature almost
so these are very cold even though
they're much much warmer than the
original superconducting
um
properties of the original
superconductors found by camera lens
back in the early 1900s when he became
the first to liquefy
the element
liquify the element hydrogen liquid
hydrogen then he put different materials
in it measured the resistance and it
happened to be that lead was uh
demonstrating zero electrical resistance
when it was cooled to liquid nitrogen
which means that it transitions from an
ordinary metal with finite resistance
and therefore heating when you pass a
current through it to zero resistance
and no heating when you pass current
through it once it goes below about 11
Kelvin in the case of lead and then
since then many many materials were
discovered at different temperatures
always trying to get higher and higher
in a quest to get to room temperature
superconductivity because then you
wouldn't even need liquid nitrogen which
though cheaper compared to liquid helium
liquid helium is about the cost of a
decent bottle of wine or you know a
liter of wine is about the same as a
liter of helium liquid helium
and liquid nitrate is about the cost of
a fine you know liter of Coke or some
other soda you know premium Cola not the
kind that I used to be given as a kit so
these materials are you know not free
they're expensive you know compared to
room temperature where you need no
cooling mechanism liquid or otherwise to
cool them down
so there's considered to be two types of
superconductors so-called type 1 type 2
very creative
uh and they're really of interest to
physicists primarily and has to do with
the way that the phase of the material
changes upon cooling down in a so-called
critical temperature
and it's not as important for us to get
into except the fact that it does allow
you once you claim superconductivity the
fellow physicist scientists will want to
know what kind of superconductivity is
it is it of a type 1 superconductor
or type 2 superconductor
and they really do differ Only You Know
by the behavior of magnetic field
penetration
in typical superconductors that are used
the original ones like lead and so forth
are pure and they're usually type one
there is complete exclusion of magnetic
field even when embedded in a strong
external field is shown here in blue
there'll be no uh there'll be no
magnetic field penetration now if you
then allow the magnetic field to
penetrate either by
because of the fact that you're using a
type 2 superconductor some of the flux
can penetrate in if you're not well
below the critical temperature
um it will they'll all behave in that
they'll allow magnetic field to
penetrate once you're above this
critical temperature they become just
like a normal metal the metals don't
screen magnetic fields the way they
screen electric fields and that's a
Hallmark of superconductors that we can
use to then determine if the claims are
actually accurate because if they're
superconductors they should exhibit
these behaviors
and then we can ask the question well
how disputed are these behaviors the
other things that can happen to the
various types of superconductors type 2
circonductors can be Frozen
and you can actually trap a magnetic
field inside of them because as I said
before they allow the penetration of a
field within them unlike a type 1
superconductor
so you can pin them and get them Frozen
in place and these vortices are
effectively behaving allowing them this
thing to have a permanent magnetic field
once you cool it down you'll have some
ambient field and that's why they become
uh they exhibit this levitation effect
where if you cool down a superconductor
below its critical temperature it's in
the earth's field and it will trap some
magnetic field within it and then it
will then levitate above an ordinary
static room temperature room pressure
permanent uh permanent magnet
and this could be these high magnetic
field objects that you can buy on Amazon
these uh very high fields or Rare Earth
element magnets or just an electromagnet
and so they can be used for levitation
which would allow almost frictionless
travel of trains and other
transportation
again the uh these the history of
superconductivity really began because
the history of cryogenic fluids so in
1908 Cameron Linens who's a Dutch
physicist had had the ability because of
something called the Hanson Linde cycle
uh that and not the Andre Linde cycle
which we'll be talking with Professor
Linde about inflation the Multiverse
it's coming up soon so stay tuned for
that
so uh Cameron arms he used this uh
advancements in cryogenic technology to
liquefy helium and he actually cooled it
way below its uh ambient pressure
boiling point of 4.2 Kelvin so then he
dunked different things in it and I said
lead before I meant Mercury so he put
mercury wire in it measured the voltage
versus current relationship and found
that it behaved as if it were obeying
Ohm's law but with a zero amount of
resistance it was really fascinating and
of course this attracted a lot of
attention that people want to understand
how it was actually occurring
and uh some of the greatest Minds in
history tried to Grapple with it
including Einstein Feynman and most were
unsuccessful
and despite the tremendous advancements
in sort of the classical theory of how
these things would behave it really took
the three gentlemen at the bottom
bardeen Cooper and schreefer and
recognized Leanne Cooper anywhere he's
the guy in the middle
um they discovered 1957 the effect that
allowed a lattice material to create the
bonding between otherwise repulsive
electronic electron Pairs and so that
was that was a critical discovery
and this is theoretical nature and then
was applied to other types of
superconductors by then the race was on
to get higher and higher temperatures
because it was known for a long time
that you could get
a tremendous number of applications
from superconductivity if applied to
technological applications
and so the race was on to do higher and
higher temperatures because it's very
inconvenient
to use liquid helium all the time it's
very expensive so in the 1980s two
scientists George bednars and Carl
Muller discovered that if you took this
type of material that Jesus you get your
embarium copper and copper oxide that
you could get them to become
superconducting at temperatures higher
then then 4.2 Kelvin so these were some
of the first so-called higher
temperature superconductors not very
high it's only 10 times higher than the
temperature of interstellar space and
the causing microwave background
temperature but nevertheless this
material allowed them the year after
they want to know about prize which is
very rare it's one of the first ones
that actually adhered to
that actually adhered to what Alfred
Nobel stipulated in his will as I point
out losing the Nobel Prize
that he wanted the Nobel Prize to go to
somebody who demanded a discovery or an
invention in the preceding year
unlike say the Higgs boson which was
awarded 40 plus years maybe closer to 50
years after the prediction by Hague
zenglart
Hagen
um and my quantum mechanics group Theory
teacher Professor Jerry garelnick
so this was actually perfectly suited
Nobel Prize to the intent of Alfred
Nobel and you know how I've railed on
about that I won't go on much further
except to say that a discovery just as
the discovery of a higher temperature
you know less than 10 times higher
temperature
revolutionized things so much that they
were awarded a Nobel Prize so too would
another factor of 10 in temperature and
Kelvin scale at least almost would that
lead to a Nobel Prize everybody believes
that if we can define a high temperature
superconductor that whoever does that
will win a Nobel Prize
so inspired by their work
um you know researchers in Houston
and Alabama
um did a an experiment on this ethereum
copper yatrium uh barium oxide which is
called yibaco
it has a super temperature of 93 Kelvin
which is much higher than the
temperature of liquid nitrogen so this
is very easy to cool down below its
critical temperature and then you get
all the cool uses of superconductivity
and so this is less than a year after
the Nobel Prize was awarded
and then you could produce commercially
this material you could use it in wires
you could use it as um
uh as a levitation mechanism as I've
said
but it doesn't have quite as many uses
as a pure you know Elemental wire piece
of mercury or copper even sorry copper
doesn't aluminum uh and so forth these
are not as useful because you can't
really cause them to carry like very
large currents they have a credit
so-called critical current and that's
another Hallmark that we're going to use
to assess and appraise the validity of a
claim of high temperature
superconductivity what is its critical
temperature what is this critical
current what is this critical magnetic
field what type of phase transition is
it those are all Hallmarks that have to
be passed by any reasonable claim of
superconducting phenomena
so many of these new ones use so-called
cup rates
and prior to this
um
prior to this discovery by our
Announcement by the Diaz group the
record holder was
um was this Lan Venom uh d c hydron Deca
hydron must be lanthanum decahydride so
it's 10 hydrogens and lanthanum it's not
that very complicated material
and it doesn't have a cup right
um and it superconducts uh you know at a
frosty temperature but a temperature
that I've enjoyed many many times at the
South Pole and elsewhere negative 23
Celsius it's not that not that bad
um speaking from experience but it
requires an incredible amount of
pressure it's 150 gigapascal uh you know
the pressure that would be basically
prohibitive to ever construct now you'll
hear in my conversation with Felix
flicker which is coming up
on his wonderful new book The Magic
of physics you'll hear more about why
this is uh so crucial to have this room
pressure ambient pressure behavior and
that's what's clean with these high
temperature superconductors that we're
going to turn
so here's the current nature paper an
Evidence of near ambient
superconductivity in an n-doped
luteinium hydride so this is not a
copper one the the last author is
actually the lead Pi of this project and
so it's um it's not alphabetical either
so again this is a little bit more
technical
when you have bound pairs of electrons
called Cooper pairs they have a
precursor property which is the phase
transition below a critical temperature
and that's how you recognize that
they've gone from normal you know above
zero resistance not non-zero resistance
to true zero resistance
there are other phenomena other
properties including the heat capacity
how much
temperature rise do you do you get in
the material for a given amount of
energy injected into it that will have a
discontinuity the meissner effect
already talked about which is the
magnetic field expulsion
and also you can measure the
susceptibility which is the amount of of
Applied magnetic field is required to
get a produced magnetic field in a
material and that has this crucial
property that you'll actually get a
negative sign so you'll get you apply a
strong magnetic field to a true
superconductor it will have an uh
opposite will generated opposite or
diamagnetic magnetic magnetization
and this will occur at a critical
they'll also exhibit a critical magnetic
field above which you will not see
superconductivity
it breaks down there's also the critical
temperature
so we use these in our detectors for the
Simon's array and the Simon's
Observatory here's one from my former
graduate student who's now a postdoc you
see Berkeley Lindsay Lowry
and it shows us a change in resistance
of our transition Edge superconducting
detectors these are our bellometers that
we use to measure the faint CMB signal
and you see it drops from some finite
resistance and about 1 ohm to zero and
it does so over very very narrow
temperature range it looks nearly
vertical but it's not quite vertical
and we use that intermediate region
where it's red basically as a
thermometer so when there's a small
change in temperature because the
velometer is heating up because it's
seeing a slightly higher patch of
temperature on the sky because the
cosmic background radiations
polarization is brighter there you'll
see this behavior and it will change and
rise or raise or lower it's it's
resistance and so we use it as a almost
perfect noiseless thermometer
when it goes below the critical
temperature it's almost useless now it's
shown here as having a finite resistance
of 0.2 ohms but that's all that 0.2 ohms
is all from our electrical resistance
that's not associated with the
superconductor so that's like other
copper wire we have to get this out of
the cryostat somehow and you see that
this is way below room temperature this
is almost at absolute zero so there's
finite
um ordinary wire like copper wire and
some copper and aluminum Alloys and
stuff so we we do use it um uh in all of
our astrophysic sensors and many sensors
will be using this in the years to come
so you see again we've got a bunch of
different properties you claim you have
a new superconductor great let's test it
out let's see if it first meets the
definition does it superconduct zero
electrical resistance
does it have a heat capacity discount
annuity you can measure that does it
exhibit the meissner effect
does it expel magnetic fields does it
have a magnetic susceptibility that's
negative indicative of diamagnetism does
it have a critical magnetic field and
does it have a critical temperature
dependence on the external magnetic
field
so I described already this property of
type 1 type 2 there's a critical
temperature below which all fields are
expelled in a type 1.
type 2 there could be flux within it and
that's just kind of a diagram taken from
uh Wikipedia the source of all
scientific knowledge
now here's an interesting plot not uh
Bryce collected it shows all these
different you know chemistry was my
nightmare subject I I never really uh
was uh was quite comfortable with
chemistry in in high school or college
so forgive me if I mangle these names
but you see the temperature scale and
you see the different years in which
these superconductors were discovered
starting way on the left discovering
Mercury and then lead
uh was slightly a higher critical
temperature these are all at ambient
pressure
except for the one that's marked uh
lanthanum decahydride or last 10 which
required this huge pressure
and does superconduct at these extremely
high temperatures
um extremely high pressures and also
extremely high temperatures we're
getting up to room temperature showing
us about 300 Kelvin is the classical
accepted definition of it
so starting at the lower left corner
going up to the right temperature is
increasing
and
um and the year is increasing for some
of these things but you really sort of
hit the wall
um and even in the year 2000 so this is
almost a hundred years after its
Discovery more than 100 years after
discovery superconductivity
and the green dots are sort of petering
out they're really not able to get much
higher up in uh in superconducting
temperature
um until uh with ordinary materials like
just simple
um you know divalent or you know
commonly available
um compounds then in 1987
you see the uh discovered the Ziti and
barium copper oxides so you see those
Skyrocket up about 90 100 Kelvin the
1986 ones are measured the first high
temperature superconductor the so-called
it was above the temperature of the
sniobium germanium compound
and that led to the Nobel Prize as I
mentioned before and then it kind of
skyrockets up and then it plateaus again
and then you start requiring higher and
higher pressures now it's not exactly
clear to me why the pressure comes into
play so much except for the fact that
that this is a mystery to my theoretical
condensed matter colleagues like
Professor Jorge Hirsch which is why I
wanted to have them on the show today so
you do need higher pressure
and uh for some of these things to
really start to interact and they don't
understand why or exactly why some
people have ideas as to why high
pressure comes into play and I asked
Felix flicker about this and and it's
still an up uh open debate why is this
the case
so the claim in this current paper
Diaz's team is that they found a
superconducting luteum nitrogen hydrogen
compound critical temperature of 294
Kelvin so that's like 12 degrees below
room temperature you know it's like 60
degrees 65 degrees Fahrenheit
they're calling this near ambient
pressure can kilo bars not that high and
they show the behavior of the different
uh of the compound as they're changing
the pressure they put inside of a a cell
a pressure cell where they can increase
the pressure compressing it and then
they're running AC and DC currents
through it and they're also checking its
magnetic field when they switch the
magnetic field or they keep it constant
and that's what they're doing they're
they're showing that it they're claiming
that it does satisfy these different
properties no resistance it has the
proper magnetic diamagnetism
it has heat capacity discontinuity and
it reduces the critical temperature when
you have a magnetic field
so that that also isn't super practical
you have to have a huge magnet to make
it lower its temperature but but anyway
it's satisfying the claim is that
satisfying all these properties that
make it a classical superconductor
here's their setup this is where it gets
really cool
they put it inside what's called a
diamond Anvil cell where they have this
huge capacity for pressure and squishing
this material but it doesn't have to be
squished all that much they're able to
put in
um with ordinary metal Platinum
non-superconducting metal foil probes
and you see those there and they
compress it in the cell that also has
Diamond powder in it for suspension and
mechanical purposes and then they're
measuring out what's called a four-point
measurement they're using two leads to
measure voltage and another two to
measure current so the voltage is
measured across the sample and the
current is measured through the sample
and then they can change the temperature
they can heat up the sample
and they can also measure the
temperature using a thermostat basically
a thermo a thermometer called the
thermocouple
so they go through they pressurize it
they measure the temperature at
different pressures they put this odd
sample in and they have pictures of it
here it is so it's this little chunk and
there you see the Platinum electrodes
coming in on the left and then it's
showing its resistant boom it looks
clear as day I mean it's clearly super
conducting it's going to zero resistance
the pressure is 10 kilobars in 1K 16
kilobars and then as a function of the
temperature is lowering as you get to
higher and higher pressures so that's
actually kind of the opposite of what
you might want you'd or what you know so
this is behaving in a very positive way
that the critical temperature is getting
uh is going up as you reduce the
pressure which is kind of cool because
you'd like it to be zero critical you
like the temperature that it transitions
to zero resistance to be
to be room temperature or even higher
the room temperature if you're using it
in the desert or something to conduct
electricity from giant solar panels or
solar water heater generators steam
turbines uh you'd like that to be maybe
slightly higher than room temperature
maybe 310 Kelvin and you'd like it to be
zero kilobar you'd like to not have to
have carry around a diamond Anvil uh
presser with you at all points so they
do this they show it's super conducting
zero resistance and then they are
measuring as a function of pressure on
the right Its Behavior now another topic
is the specific heat how much
how much heat is stored for a given
change in temperature how much energy is
stored this behaves properly it exhibits
the characteristic specific heat
discontinuity
and it's
um Ohm's Law changes from linear which
is Ohm's Law V equals I times R the
non-linear when it gets below the
critical temperature
so far so good they do magnetization
measurements they measure that is
um in a uh a vibrating sample
magnetometer where they're actually
moving it to generate a changing AC
alternating current magnetic field
um moving it back and forth moving it up
and down and then also having a pickup
coil to measure the resulting magnetic
field and they see as they do this what
the
um what the behavior is like and this is
where the controversial Behavior comes
in according to my colleague Jorge
Hirsch claims that the background
subtraction technique that they're using
is problematic and we'll get to some of
that in just a bit
they measure the DC magnetization the AC
magnetization well there's zero field
and field cooling conditions those are
technical
um technical properties
they mentioned the onset of
magnetization they see the magnetization
changes in response to sample pressure
this is all great
well what does this look like well they
don't know exactly what it is
um statistically this luteinium
Hydro nitride this has been made by
taking this foil of luteinium which I
don't know where you can get them but
I'm sure they can get you some and maybe
even sell you some
and it's uh made by heating it in a
hydrogen Atomic or sorry molecular
hydrogen molecular nitrogen gas mixture
up to 63 Celsius which is you know
toasty but not crazy high temperature
and not under high pressure that's just
to make it
uh they characterize it using what's
called Raman spectroscopy which is type
of similar to like fluorescent
spectroscopy
they don't know exactly the composition
or how much of these different they're
called stoichiometric relationships
again I failed chemistry I didn't failed
chemistry but uh it's been a while
decades since I had chemistry
um
and now we get to some of the so it
checks all the boxes okay it's making uh
zero resistance it's having magnetic
susceptibility as a diamagnet it's
having a critical temperature Behavior
it has critical field Behavior it has a
um otherwise you know completely
completely uh I don't say classical but
it has a completely objectively
well-behaved magnetic field are
superconducting properties so what is a
controversy about it seems like they're
you know ticking all the boxes a lot of
this comes down to who do you trust do
you trust the experimentalist
um or is there a reason to maybe suspect
them is there something wrong with what
they're doing and so I'm going to take
you through some of the controversy
again it's too bad my colleague decided
not to be here for this but maybe I'll
get them some other time
um and uh so let's go through some of
the complaints about this particular
finding there was a response and we'll
have this in the show notes down below
that the discovery of superconductivity
uh this is by Dirk vandemarle and Jorge
Hirsch uh and they talk about the
discovery of room temperature
superconductivity for carbonaceous
sulfur hydride under high pressure is it
different type of materials not the
luteinium and they measure uh this and
they claim this but then they say the
susceptibility again this is getting
into the magnetic susceptibility
the background they claim the authors
diesel the background signal determined
from a non-superconducting sample has
been subtracted from the data from a
thorough analysis we show the data are
incompatible with the notion that the
susceptibility data are obtained from
the measured voltage
using a background connection correction
on the other hand the data are
compatible with the reverse procedure
namely the measured voltage is obtained
by adding a background signal containing
noise to what was reported as a
background correct is susceptibility for
all six of the reported pressures our
analysis leads to conclusion like that
one the reported background corrected
susceptibility data are pathological
two they were not obtained by the method
described in the paper nor by any one of
the alternative three methods that were
subsequently provided by the authors and
three the measured voltage data are not
raw data
so it's basically alleging
improper conduct a laboratory conducts
perhaps but it gets worse in some sense
or better in some sense
um so
uh there was another manuscript that
this one was submitted by just by Jorge
Hirsch it was published
and this is called uh on the room
temperature superconductivity of
carbonation sulfur hydride
um here I provide analysis of the
underlying data the analysis calls into
question the General accepted view of
the carbonaceous sulfur hydride is a
room temperature superconductor
and he goes through in great detail what
is the notion of what they claim to have
detected
um now this fell into a lot of uh a lot
of attention so this was actually
reported
in uh in all the popular press and it
was reported at this meeting in the
so-called March meeting of the American
physical Society the plot kind of
thickened after this
um
and this is from a science paper and
journal science science
about the treatment of Jorge Hirsch
after he was banned from publishing in
What's called the archive which is the
largest repository of scientific and
exchange of scientific documents in the
world right now it's an open source
um Open Access a system to publish
preprints before they get accepted under
peer review sometimes they're not
accepted under peer review
okay so they banned him they banned
Jorge Hirsch a theoretical physicist at
UCSD from posting papers for six months
any Jorge's quoted saying the band is
very unfair I can't work if I can't
publish papers well not really Pub not
free to publish papers you just can't
put them on archive but anyway
now the southern scientists archives ban
and removal of papers amounted to
stifling scientific debate and here they
quote my other colleagues here at UCSD
Nigel goldenfeld Diana rovas another
physicist agreed squelching what is
essentially a purely scientific exchange
even one where the respective parties
engage in some distasteful accusations
is highly problematic
there are no papers and according to the
archives administrators there are no
papers in this whole chain that are
rejected because we do not like the
scientific content
says uh Ralph luigiers a physicist at
the University of Amsterdam who is the
pre-print servers board chair people's
emotions became too effective they got
acrimonious
then it goes on to describe uh what the
archive is all about how many papers are
accepted uh and how it's voluntarily
moderated by people that there's
legitimate scientific research interests
of the community
papers that don't appear to be
scientifically sound or use
unprofessional language can be rejected
review boards then manage appeals
rejections are rare perhaps one percent
of submissions said Stein sigurdson's
their executive director
if we allow this stuff all this stuff he
says Paul Finley says rather a family a
theoretical University Oxford and
advisory committee if we allow this
stuff what's the difference between the
archive and Twitter
indeed
so moderators believe that Jorge Hirsch
here UCSD crossed the line and paper is
critiquing the October 2020 nature
publication by team len by ranga Diaz
physicist at the University of Rochester
the paper reporting the discovery of a
hydrogen containing material under
intense pressure superconducts at near
room temperature was held as a
culmination of a century-long quest
as I said before
now then it got really interesting
Hearst did
um Hersh asked Diaz for the raw data he
said Diaz rebuffed him repeatedly
eventually Hirsch did receive some data
from one of Diaz's co-authors and that's
kind of uh one of the sticking points
and in August 2021 Hurst submitted his
own analysis
to both the archive and physical C
the paper was titled on the AC magnetic
susceptibility of a room temperature
superconductor anatomy of a probable
scientific fraud
so pretty harsh words after publishing
it online physical C removed the article
because it contained data published
without the original team's permission
and then the archive took it down in
December
then the plot thickens 2021 Diaz and one
of his collaborators Oscar and salamat
at the University of Nevada Las Vegas
posted a response to Hirsch's criticisms
included some of their raw data
and a December her submitted two papers
analyzing those raw data and followed up
with three more papers all them
responses to work by Diaz
and his colleagues they blocked all five
archived it her said posting multiple
submissions also been delayed for weeks
or more and papers were taken down even
after they were posted
last week the paper the site archive
site also removed a paper from Diaz and
Salama due to inflammatory content in
unprofessional language
so this is this is wild this is
happening in theoretical and
experimental condensed matter physics
now harsh to his credit defended Diaz
and Solomon's paper in an effort and an
email to their administrators it
prevents scientific arguments the
community should be able to judge in
their merits rather than prevented by
doing so by your arbitrary
self-righteous to Quorum standards
they've been invited to modify the
offending language and resubmit it and a
modified version on Hirsch's papers on
which she's the second offer has been
reposted
modification is not like that happy
happened with Hirsch's other offending
papers when she was the first or only
author
sigridson says he's unable to discuss
the case but bands can occur for other
reasons
we don't want to be flooded by separate
comments and single papers our
moderators are a noise suppression
machine he says
other physicist worry moderators are
making arbitrary judgments and we don't
know what those prejudices might be
according to Brian Josephson who I hope
to get on the podcast someday about
Prize winner also controversial and his
own right
a Creator inventor of the Josephson
Junction Joseph in fact which we use in
our squid amplifiers this new discovery
is now in a room ambient pressure as
well but it's the same team and to add
to that kind of uh some of the questions
are you know Perhaps it is the fact
that Diaz has started this company on
Earthly materials and he has already
made according to
um uh some of the claims and articles
and TechCrunch and elsewhere because a
new ludium-based material is
superconducting a much lower pressure as
many other research groups will attempt
to reproduce the experiment Dr Dion said
he wants to provide a more precise
recipe on how to make the compound and
share samples but intellectual property
issues need to be resolved first he
founded a company unearthly materials
that plans to turn the research into
profits
and allegedly he is he claimed that uh
he had obtained 20 million dollars in
funding they made claims that could
later not be verified so TechCrunch
reports uh just last week on Earthly
materials claimed to have big name
investors but they weren't all on board
star claims is on the cusp of the
superconductor breakthrough despite the
questionable scientific record
I'll have links to that as well
so they want to capitalize in a research
there's nothing wrong with that
necessarily though it's it's curious as
to whether or not he or his company can
actually make a lot of money he patent
something like this
um you know it's a material can you
really own a material if there's
something proprietary about it that no
one else could figure out should you Pro
should you
um you know put a patent on something
that could benefit the whole planet
should you try to leverage it to make
money and so this author of this
TechCrunch article Tim decant
which we link to uh talks about uh talks
about the a video which was uh stumbled
upon by the author of a virtual talk
that Diaz gave to Scientific society and
Sri Lankan investors in a university
which he claims to have raised a million
dollar seed round and 20 million dollars
series a from Earth and materials and
you'll know that I talked to
uh none other than
um David Friedberg co-host of the all-in
podcast and and David said he'd give his
right arm for a room temperature
superconductivity so David's arm is at
stake here
um and it's certainly not clear if he'll
have to give it up but some of the other
investors that were on site according to
Diaz
the seed round featured Union Square
Ventures
um the the founder of Spotify Daniel Act
um and uh and then the series a round
apparently included none other than Sam
Altman openai's uh uh leader so this is
an incredibly you know complex difficult
and uh Tangled super conducting web
trying to figure it all out is not easy
but it does highlight this notion that
media Academia
are in collaboration just as the
military and Industry are in
collaboration
is it dangerous can it lead to abuses or
maybe incentivize fraud in some cases
perhaps
there's a lot at stake and it's
interesting to note that these things
have to do with one of our greatest
challenges climate change right one of
the greatest challenges that we're
facing is you know the losses due to
energy Transportation due to the fact
that we use actual conductive materials
that have non-vanishing resistance
they're ordinary materials so they lose
copper loses 20 to 30 percent of the
energy that's transporting so that's a
huge hit in efficiency so we're going to
change all that reducing the need at
room temperature to just have loss due
to heat from the copper wires that are
used for transmission lines
we'd also be able to utilize them as I
said before for transportation near
frictionless or just mere air resistance
and many many other scientific
applications
medicine and otherwise we wouldn't need
these huge cryogenic have you ever had
an NMR
MRI as we now call it you've undoubtedly
heard that uh incredible you know sound
of the cooler and that's actually used
in the magnets
um those are superconductors they need
to be cool to look at Helium and liquid
nitrogen uh is not sufficient to
generate the temperatures or yet your
barium copper oxide cannot produce the
magnetic fields you need to image say
the brain or something so you could
actually reduce that that would benefit
the world in a way that Alfred Nobel
clearly intended so double prize is at
stake attention for the universities are
at stake
climate change is at stake you could
have room temperature super Computing
devices using superconductors so quantum
computers operating qubits that are used
are like these Joseph Junctions uh again
I hope to get Brian Joe I've been in
contact with him hopefully I'll come on
so there's a tremendous amount at stake
Prestige money Fame attention
and so much more makes it such an
interesting topic for me to look at as
an outsider just a physics interested
nerdy Outsider but somebody who
um you know has no direct stake in this
but as an interested party I think we
can all get behind the fact that these
announcements and the vetting of them
and the acrimony and that science people
think scientists are just these
happy-go-lucky types they're just
curious and passionate and they never
have any bad signs or just you know
stroking our beards and thinking about
the universe or non-existent beards in
some cases so where do we go from here
well I'll continue to pay attention to
this because as I said I'm incredibly
interested in it even as a lay person in
this field although I do use
superconductors that use cryogenics and
but I'm fascinated with it so I'll
Endeavor to keep you abreast of this but
I'll also bring into account more topics
as I talked about in a video at the end
of December last year with uh professor
Charles seif who's a journalism
Professor former math physics Aficionado
himself
we talked about the discovery of fusion
by uh Lawrence Livermore National
Laboratory announced at the end of last
year as a breakthrough in in power and
and hope for you know Green energy too
cheap to meter so
part of my mission bring you the best
and brightest in the universe and
sometimes unveil the messy side of being
a scientist it's not all pretty I don't
want to make people feel the impression
that being a scientist is all just
everybody just contemplating the
universe and how it can benefit The
Human Condition it's not like that
but hopefully we'll Explore More
together and let me know what you think
about this video uh leave a thumbs up
leave a comment even better and a thumbs
up
leave a thumbs down that also helps you
wouldn't believe it leave a thumbs down
but tell me what you'd like me to
improve about the presentation topics
other things if you like more of these
deep dimes kind of like in office hours
uh and uh let me know what you think
okay
till next time
foreign